[Music]
fans of Shadowhunters were sad to see
that the show had been cancelled but
there have been a lot of clues that
indicate that the show might actually be
coming back stay tuned to see which
network the show's producer has been
having conversations with are you new
around here don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and subscribe to
the things for more great content like
this now onto 10 signs Shadowhunters is
actually coming back for season 4
it was the most-watched show fans of
Shadowhunters were extremely upset when
they realized that the show wouldn't be
renewed well we don't need to be upset
because the show may actually be coming
back how do we know just look at how
popular the show was when the show
premiered it was one of free forms most
watched new TV series in the previous
two years sure the ratings may have gone
down over time but come on you know just
let go of one of your most popular shows
like that that would be like getting a
Ferrari and then refusing to ever drive
it again because it had a flat tire it
makes no sense the show could turn
around it just needs to be given more
time if you look at the history of shows
with high ratings lots of them have been
saved so if we're just going off
popularity and how much people love the
show then we have a sneaking suspicion
that the show will come back taking the
show off air wouldn't be smart for free
form financially or in the hearts of
people that watch the channel if free
form knows what's in their best interest
they will bring the show back whatever
it costs Netflix is saving shows anyone
who's a fan of television knows that
we've been here before so much so that
we should have actually been expecting
it no matter how much people love a show
networks will often pull it from the air
for reasons other than viewer ratings
but a show not being renewed doesn't
mean that it's the end of the story
especially nowadays it's quite the
contrary because of a little thing
called Netflix Netflix has become a
powerhouse of television it's saved a
number of shows that have been cancelled
from Lucifer to Arrested Development a
television station cancellation does not
necessarily mean death for the show in
fact some shows actually do better on
Netflix than they ever did on their
original television station and would
you rather watch the show on Netflix
anyway that way you can binge watch the
whole storyline without having to wait a
week or so between episodes Netflix are
you listening
you need to save this show just look at
all of the people who watched
show on freeform imagine how many more
would watch it online it would be insane
the show could probably go on for at
least a few more seasons it won awards
so we've already told you how amazing
the show is right it's downright
fabulous and we aren't the only ones who
think so in fact the show is so great
that a won awards the show went from
being a typical teen show about
mythology and romance it's rare that
I've ever felt this way about someone to
being critically acclaimed it actually
won a GLAAD Media Award for Outstanding
Drama Series you might think that all
these awards are in the past so they
couldn't possibly matter but that
couldn't be further from the truth
shows that when Awards are more likely
to be renewed even though Shadowhunters
wasn't initially renewed the awards are
a good indicator that we might see the
show again if not on the same network
then at least picked up by some other
network or streaming service honestly we
don't really care what channel the show
moves to as long as we get to see the
rest of the story play out but seriously
think about it which shows do you think
have a chance of coming back from the
dead
shows that have won awards or shows that
haven't it's a no-brainer
if awards are any indication we'll
definitely be seeing Shadowhunters again
there's too much story every story has a
beginning a middle and an end that's one
of the big reasons we watched movies and
television shows in the first place we
know we can expect to go through the
full spectrum of what a story usually
entails we'll see the characters start
their journeys we'll be right with them
through their hardships and then at the
end of the day we'll get a resolution to
the story without that resolution we'd
feel incomplete if you look at the arc
that most stories and shows follow then
you won't have to worry about
Shadowhunters the story has to have a
proper ending and frankly there's just
too much story to tell without going
into a fourth season sure the channel
has conceded to giving the series a
two-part series finale but even that
isn't enough there are too many loose
ends to tie ah
and it can't be done in a two-part
finale to give the fans everything that
they deserve and make sure that people
feel that the story is complete the show
basically requires at least one more
season you're gonna make it back
you hear me if the show doesn't come
back and the finale is truly the end
then the story will feel rushed and who
likes a rushed story it only got
canceled because of money shows get
cancelled for different reasons some
shows are canceled because the main
characters quit and if that's the case
then there's really no way to come back
from that main characters can't really
be replaced some shows are canceled
because there aren't enough people
watching those shows don't really have a
chance to come back either why would
anyone bring back a show that no one
watched on the first go-around hey would
it but there is another reason that a
show might be cancelled and that is
because of money
according to freeform that is the reason
that Shadowhunters was cancelled while
that stinks for the network it's still
not the worst news for the show unlike
the other reasons for being canceled a
show can definitely come back from this
just because the show is too expensive
for one network doesn't mean it will be
too expensive for another or maybe the
fans will become so outraged with the
cancellation of their favorite show that
they'll start a GoFundMe and make enough
money to put the show back on the air
what we're trying to say is that lack of
funds is an obstacle but not a huge one
other shows have survived cancellation
television has been around for a long
time and in all that time shows have
come and gone shows have come from being
at the pinnacle of ratings to losing the
majority of their viewers that's the
nature of the business because of this
up-and-down nature of television it only
makes sense that some shows be canceled
and then brought back in fact you may
not even know that some of your favorite
shows were once cancel any Arrested
Development fans out there well
apparently that show was on the brink of
being cancelled since it first came out
the show was eventually cancelled after
three seasons but there were such an
outpouring of fan love that Netflix
ended up picking the series back up this
just goes to show that if the fan base
is strong enough the show can come back
if Arrested Development could be picked
back up almost 10 years later than a
show with as many fans of Shadowhunters
definitely has a chance to be reinstated
when we look at it this way we'd
honestly be pretty surprised if the show
didn't return in one way or another
still my beating heart when it does come
back it might not be the same exact show
we all know and love but at least we'll
get some version of the series
Katherine's response when a show is
cancelled it's important to pay
attention to those who were close to the
show the
actors actresses directors crew and
camera people are all important they all
typically have very important insight
into what happened in those last few
days the show when Shadowhunters was
cancelled we paid close attention to
Catherine McNamara's response she's the
one who played the main character Clary
she said that she and the rest of the
cast were just as surprised as the fans
this is important to pay attention to
because it means the show was not going
downhill if Catherine wasn't surprised
at all at the cancellation of the show
then that would have meant that there
was lots of turmoil going on behind the
scene in her statement she also says
quote no matter what happens from here
end quote
this means that Catherine doesn't know
what's gonna happen from this point on
which means the show may be coming back
at some point if there was no chance of
the show coming back then Catherine
would have been a lot more final instead
she left her statement open-ended making
all of us think that maybe there was a
chance this wouldn't be the last that
we'd be seeing of her everyone else's
response like we said it's important to
pay attention to the things the cast and
crew say after a show ends we've shown
you what the main character of the show
Hedison but what about everyone else
while some of the cast like Dominic
Sherwood was sad and said goodbye to
faith others weren't so quick to close
the door on what was such a great show M
rod Tuvia didn't say goodbye at all in
fact she actually tweeted that she
wasn't ready to say goodbye when you see
the cast tweet things like this then you
can let out a sigh of relief if a show
ever does get reinstated and all of the
cast members would have to be willing to
come back to the show if the cast
doesn't seem to be sad that a show is
ending then you can bet they won't be
jumping at the opportunity to join the
show again once it comes back on the air
M rod sadness is actually a good thing
for fans of the show it means that she
would probably be be willing to come
back and do the show again if anyone
wanted to pick it up judging by the
tweets from the rest of her classmates
we would guess that she isn't the only
one who feels this way fans reactions
while the cast's reactions to their show
being canceled are certainly important
it isn't the most important thing to pay
attention to not by a long shot
there is one thing that's way more
important and can give you a better
gauge on whether the show will be picked
back up or not want to know what that is
it's the fans reactions to the news time
and time again when a show
brought back on the air it's the fans
that put it there just take a look back
at our Arrested Development example it
was all the fans that got that show back
on the air all it takes is one look at
Twitter and you can see that the fans of
Shadowhunters were super upset to see
their show go down these fans are
rallying together and they don't seem
like they're gonna take no for an answer
we wouldn't be surprised if some got
together and made a petition to get the
show back on the air you can do it
together fan support is one of the main
things that networks like to see if
they're gonna consider putting a show
back on television if a network or
streaming service is gonna pick up a
show they want to make sure that people
will watch it ongoing discussions we've
told you to pay attention to almost
everything that has happened with the
show since the announcements from the
fan reactions to the cast reactions it's
all important but one beam of hope that
really puts us over the edge is what the
show's producer has been said producer
Martin Moskovitz told deadline that he
and the other members of the constantine
film company were so surprised by the
dedication that fans had shown to the
show and getting it to come back he said
that they had all seen the save
Shadowhunters hashtag and were amazed
since seeing that he and some other big
names were going into discussions with
reform and Netflix to see how they could
keep the story going did you hear that
there are already conversations going on
about bringing the show back the fans
have already proven that the show is
worth a second look we can't wait to see
what comes of these conversations and
Netflix would be crazy not to pick up a
show with such a big fan base just think
of how many people would sign up for
Netflix accounts just to watch the show
it would be a win-win situation for
everyone that's it for 10 signs
Shadowhunters is actually coming back
for season four are you convinced that
the show is coming back let us know in
the comments
[Music]